las ranuras dobles son muy buenas porque
nos muestran definitivamente que la luz
puede tener patrones de interferencia si
dirigiéramos un láser verde a través de
esto lo que veríamos en la pantalla
sería algo como esto tenemos estos
puntos brillantes pero están difuminados
entre sí tenemos puntos oscuros que
están como mezclados un poco con los
puntos luminosos y es por eso que
podemos dibujar una representación
gráfica de esta forma en donde cada
punto se mezcla con el siguiente lo cual
se ve bien pero no es muy agradable ya
que si nosotros queremos realmente hacer
este experimento vamos a querer medir
algunos ángulos lo que significa que
tendremos que medir algunas distancias
la distancia de la rejilla hacia la
pantalla que me dará este lado del
triángulo y también querré medir la
distancia entre alguno de estos dos
puntos brillantes que es lo que puedo
ver pero como están difuminados nos va a
ser difícil encontrar el centro exacto
del punto a veces la luz no es tan
brillante y es muy difícil encontrar
este punto
y lo peor es que estos puntos se van
haciendo menos luminosos conforme se
alejan del centro y ese es otro problema
a veces tendremos suerte de ver el
quinto o sexto punto brillante alejados
del centro así que mi pregunta es habrá
alguna forma mejor de hacer esto hay
alguna forma de hacer que estos puntos
se definan mejor de manera que podamos
verlos más brillantes y más cantidad de
ellos y la respuesta es sí veamos cómo
hacerlo lo que tenemos que hacer es
poner más agujeros si tenemos estos
agujeros que están separados una
distancia de voy a hacer otro agujero a
la misma distancia y después haré otro
agujero a la misma distancia y así
seguiré haciendo agujeros puedo hacer
cientos o incluso miles de agujeros así
separados la misma distancia que se
encuentran extremadamente juntos y
siempre que estén separados una
distancia de algo mágico va a ocurrir si
tenemos todos estos agujeros separados
una distancia de entre sí lo que
tendremos en la pared no va
a hacer este patrón todo borroso lo que
vamos a obtener es un punto justo aquí
luego oscuridad y después otro punto
luego oscuridad y otro punto y verán que
esto continúa mucho más alejado del
centro de lo que creíamos posible porque
bueno vamos a hablar de esto cómo es que
podemos ver este patrón así la primera
onda que sale de este primer agujero va
a viajar cierta distancia hacia la
pantalla y digamos que aquí tenemos un
punto donde hay interferencia
constructiva y digamos que tenemos estos
dos agujeros para comenzar dos agujeros
nuestra doble ranura ahorita no vamos a
tomar en cuenta todos estos agujeros de
abajo llegan dos ondas que vienen de dos
agujeros y digamos que este punto
brillante corresponde a delta x igual a
una longitud de onda en otras palabras
este será el punto de interferencia
constructiva en donde la segunda onda de
este segundo agujero o segunda ranura
a una longitud de onda más comparada con
la onda del primer agujero y lo que
significa es que si yo dibujo con
cuidado una línea de aquí acá en ángulo
recto significa que este fragmento de la
segunda onda será la longitud de la ruta
extra y esto es una longitud de onda y
ya que esta segunda onda va a estar
viajando una longitud de onda más este
punto tendrá una interferencia
constructiva si yo dibujara mi onda va a
coincidir perfectamente aquí está mi
onda y digamos que la onda del primer
agujero o la primera ranura resulta que
está en este punto particular en su
ciclo imaginemos que esta primera onda
llega a este punto justo en esta parte
de su ciclo la segunda ranura ya que
está viajando una longitud de onda más
va a llegar a la pantalla en este punto
de su ciclo
ambas están llegando al mismo punto la
primera onda llega en este punto de su
ciclo y la segunda onda llega en este
punto de su ciclo
cuando este se sobreponen ya que son dos
zonas diferentes que se están
sobreponiendo en el mismo punto tendrán
interferencia constructiva ya que el
pico coincide con el pico de la otra y
si el valle coincide con el valle
también será constructiva qué pasa con
la tercera ranura o el tercer agujero
aquí es donde se empieza a poner
interesante esto la onda del tercer
agujero va a estar viajando esta
distancia qué tan lejos viajo comparada
con la segunda onda pues hacemos lo
mismo que hicimos hace un momento viajo
esa distancia y esto tiene el mismo
ángulo que aquí arriba por lo tanto esta
será la misma distancia que teníamos
aquí arriba una longitud de onda y
recordemos que encontramos esta fórmula
de por el seno de teta
es la diferencia en la longitud de la
ruta y theta es el mismo para todos así
que puedo considerar estas dos como una
doble ranura la tercera viaja a una
longitud de onda más que la segunda pero
que tanto más recorrió comparada con la
primera onda continuamos en esta línea
hacia abajo y vemos que viaja dos
longitudes de onda más lejos la onda que
sale del tercer agujero viaja dos
longitudes de onda más lejos que la
primera onda la segunda y la tercera
van a ser constructivas ya que están
separadas solamente una longitud de onda
y la tercera y la primera también van a
ser constructivas ya que están separadas
dos lambda son múltiplos enteros de
lambda y eso quiere decir que coinciden
sus varias con sus bailes y sus picos
con sus picos si la primera onda llega a
este punto aquí la onda de la segunda
ranura llega aquí y la onda de la
tercera ranura viaja dos longitudes de
onda más por lo que va a llegar en el
tercer pico todas van a estar
sobreponiéndose en
el mismo punto de su ciclo por lo que
vamos a tener interferencia constructiva
y podemos seguir haciendo esto para las
demás ranuras aquí también vamos a tener
interferencia constructiva la onda de la
cuarta ranura va a viajar una longitud
de onda más que la onda de la tercera
ranura dos longitudes de onda más que la
onda de la segunda ranura y tres
longitudes de onda más que la de la
primera ranura pero todas se van a
alinear y se van a trasladar
perfectamente por lo que tendremos un
punto extremadamente brillante aquí ya
que tenemos más ondas que están haciendo
interferencia constructiva aquí y ahora
esta es la parte donde comienza a
ponerse extraño tienen que poner mucha
atención porque a mí esa es la parte que
más trabajo me costó comprender cuando
lo estudie pues no tenía ningún sentido
para mí así que pongan atención esta es
la parte extraña si nos desviamos
ligeramente de este punto constructivo
si yo me voy un poquito más arriba de
aquí veamos qué pasa
la onda de la primera ranura va a viajar
esta distancia y la onda de la segunda
ranura va a viajar esta distancia hasta
acá la diferencia en la longitud de la
ruta no va a ser una longitud de onda
digamos que la diferencia en la longitud
de la ruta es de 1.1 longitudes de onda
digamos que la onda de la segunda ranura
no estará viajando una longitud de onda
más que la primera estará viajando 1.1
longitudes de onda más que la anterior
más que la primera onda y si la primera
onda llega a la pantalla en este punto
la segunda onda va a llegar a la
pantalla no en ese mismo punto de su
ciclo sino a 1.1 longitudes de onda
después y si dibujo todo esto por acá me
voy a quedar sin espacio voy a ponerlo
acá ya que todas estas son los mismos
puntos en el ciclo el ciclo se repite
una y otra vez 1.1 longitudes de onda
será más o menos por aquí la segunda
onda va a llegar en este punto en su
ciclo y se van atrás la paz pues podemos
decir que es parcialmente constructiva y
si sólo hubiéramos estos dos puntos
quizás tuviéramos un punto algo
brillante aquí
pero si continuamos veamos qué sucede la
onda del tercer agujero también viaja
hasta acá que tanto más lejos viajo
bueno viajo 1.1 longitudes de onda más
que la segunda onda pero viajo 1.1 más
1.1 longitudes de onda más que la onda
de la primera ranura por lo que viajo
2.2 longitudes de onda más allá que la
primera onda
vamos a aclarar mejor esto hago lo mismo
que hice con los ejemplos anteriores
aquí dibujo una línea con un ángulo
recto y está un poquito más alejada así
que la dibujo un poquito más lejos la
segunda onda viaja 1.1 longitudes de
onda más que la primera onda la onda de
la tercera ranura viaja 1.1 longitudes
de onda más que la onda de la segunda
ranura pero va a viajar 1.1 más 1.1
longitudes de onda comparada con la onda
de la primera ranura por lo que ésta va
a viajar 2.2 longitudes de onda desde la
tercera ranura al menos comparada con la
de la primera ranura en qué parte de su
ciclo llegará a la pantalla tenemos 12
longitudes de onda 2.2 estará un poquito
más lejano no hasta el fondo pero más
lejos que estos dos así que será en este
punto por aquí
podemos seguir haciendo esto vamos a ver
qué pasa
hagamos un par más esta onda tiene que
viajar esta distancia y seguramente
ustedes ya están viendo el patrón la
onda que pasa por la cuarta ranura va a
tener que viajar 1.1 longitudes de onda
más lejos que la onda de la tercera
ranura tendrá que viajar 2.2 longitudes
de onda más lejos que la onda de la
segunda ranura y viajará 3.3 longitudes
de onda más que la onda de la primera
ranura y si comparo la posición del
ciclo de esta onda con la primera será
3.3 longitudes de onda más 123 así que
va a estar por aquí y aquí estará el
punto 4 el punto 5 tendré otro en el
punto 6 otro en el punto 7 en el punto 8
en el punto 9 y en el punto 10 habré
recorrido toda una longitud de onda
completa que va a ser esto si todas
estas ondas se traslapan entre sí en
este punto que está un poquito más
alejado
de este otro punto que veremos aquí pues
podemos emparejar esto este punto y este
punto van a tener una interferencia
completamente destructiva uno está en el
máximo el otro está en el mínimo uno en
el pico otro en el valle se van a
aniquilar y podemos seguir haciendo
estas parejas este de aquí y este de acá
también se van a destruir y podemos
seguir haciendo esto con todas las
parejas de puntos así de manera que
siempre encontremos un punto que tenga
interferencia destructiva con otro y eso
significa que no vamos a tener luz
alguna en este punto aunque estemos un
poquito alejados de este punto mágico
donde tenemos interferencia constructiva
lo que significa es que en lugar de
tener un borrón en lugar de tener este
patrón este patrón borroso vamos a tener
en los puntos brillantes un punto en
cada uno de los puntos de interferencia
constructiva un punto brillante y
tendremos oscuridad entre estos puntos
brillantes lo que
es genial ya que esto nos facilita la
medición esta es una cosa buena y esto
se debe al hecho de que si tenemos
cientos o incluso miles de agujeros con
que nos desviamos tantito del punto
donde hay interferencia constructiva
debido a que estos nunca van a coincidir
perfectamente ya que conforme vamos
teniendo agujeros ninguno de éstos va a
coincidir de manera constructiva con
algún otro van a ser siempre
destructivos el segundo va a tener
interferencia destructiva con algún otro
el tercero también y el cuarto también
así sucesivamente siempre tendremos
alguna pareja destructiva por lo que
tendremos oscuridad entre estos puntos
de luz y como les comentaba a mí al
principio esto se me complicó no lo
entendía
tuve que verlo varias veces para
comprenderlo si esto no nos convence a
ustedes les recomiendo que traten de
hacer el experimento físicamente o graf
y que lo y hagan los cálculos yo aquí he
tratado de explicarles esto es lo mejor
que puedo pero es un tema un poco
complicado
esta es la idea
así que estos agujeros múltiples son
geniales
nos dan puntos que están espaciados y
perfectamente delineados ahora sí sí
quiero medir esa distancia
puedo medirla con precisión ya que tengo
puntos que me indican exactamente en
dónde está la interferencia constructiva
esta es una cosa buena y la segunda cosa
buena es que como tengo tantas ranuras
esos puntos brillantes van a durar más
tiempo y podré ver mejor algunos que no
veía antes podré ver más puntos
brillantes a los lados al menos
comparados con el otro patrón que era
muy borroso tengo más agujeros que están
interactuando y por lo tanto tendré
puntos más intensos los puntos están
mejor delineados y son más brillantes
así que a esto le damos un nombre
especial ya que es bastante útil en
lugar de tener la doble ranura estos
agujeros múltiples son mucho mejores ya
esto le llamamos rejilla de difracción
rejilla de difracción es mejor que la
doble ranura ya que nos permite ver
mejor los puntos más definidos y más
brillantes
cuántos agujeros debemos tener en la
rejilla de difracción típicamente estos
se miden en líneas por centímetro y por
líneas entendemos los agujeros por los
que pasan las ondas es decir agujeros
por centímetro o quizás también podrían
ser las partes que bloquean la luz las
líneas pero no importa típicamente
tendremos miles de líneas por centímetro
en una rejilla de difracción así de
pequeños son los espacios entre estos
agujeros y quizás ustedes se preocupen
de que aquí se complique la matemática
ya que tenemos todos estos agujeros
resulta que no esta es la mejor parte
esta relación se sigue manteniendo todos
los cálculos que hicimos con
anterioridad sirven para esta
configuración y debido a que todas estas
se alinean para los puntos buenos los
puntos mágicos en donde todos se
traslapa de tal manera que hacen una
interferencia constructiva perfecta no
importa cuántos agujeros tengamos aquí
todos van a estar interfiriendo
constructivamente de manera perfecta así
que tenemos la misma ecuación
la que encontramos antes de de por el
seno de theta es igual a m por la
longitud de onda
esto nos sigue dando los puntos
constructivos en los patrones de
interferencia constructiva en una
rejilla de difracción